You're on Mars,
it's not
particularly welcoming.
So, you'll need
the essentials.
♪♪
Food.
Water.
Air.
Shelter.
And....
Hopefully a powerful
source of energy
to help survive
your new home.
I'm Wrenn Schmidt,
and we're exploring the science
behind "For All Mankind."
What would it take
to survive on Mars?
Like our stranded
For All Mankind crew?
They could stretch what
they brought with them,
but to generate the supplies
they need long term,
they'll need a lot of power.
Fortunately our crew
could harness
the limitless energy technology
that helped define this season.
Nuclear fusion.
So, why is fusion more powerful
than the atomic energy we
already create?
Fission with an "I."
Is nuclear power
as we know it.
[ping pong sounds]
It splits an atom
which releases energy,
[buzzer]
but it also creates
radio active waste.
[alarm]
Fusion on the other hand,
fuses two Atoms.
This releases a lot more energy.
And if you use an
element like Helium 3,
you'll create a lot less waste.
So where could
we find Helium 3?
Solar winds have
been blasting
the moon for
billions of years.
Depositing an estimated
1.1 million tons
of Helium 3 on the surface.
We'd only 25 tons to power the
United States for
an entire year.
How can we get this powerful
resource from the moon?
Well the way they mine
Helium 3 in the show
is a blueprint for
what we can do.
Using a bucket wheel excavator
we could collect that
Helium rich lunar reglet.
Heat it to  700 degrees
celsius to release
the Helium 3.
Along side Oxygen
and Hydrogen.
Two other valuable
resources in space.
Which we'd separate and store.
Finally we'd transport
the Helium 3
to Mars to use
an infusion reactor.
Giving us the
power we need to
generate the essentials
for sustaining life.
Nuclear fusion
could power the future
of life on Mars.
Scientists are still trying to
crack how to get
more energy outta
fusion reactions
then they put in.
But the future fueled by
safe abundant clean energy.
Good for Mars.
Great for Earth.
Game changing
For All Mankind.